have you got some news I have I'm so
excited this is so awesome
okay seeing as how work how much
explained formally Marvel explained
whatever we got to talk about this we
can't not talk about spider-man and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe okay first
things first what does this not mean all
right what this does not mean is that
Marvel is getting the rights back to
spider-man that's not happening Marvel
has not gotten the rights back to
spider-man as much as we wish they had
as much as we wish they would they have
not but what this is is a step in the
right direction now the spider-man is a
four billion dollar project or a four
billion dollar franchise for Sony
I highly doubt they're ever gonna give
him up what happened here is that Sony
and Marvel struck a deal if spider-man
appears in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
Sony's gonna get to reboot spider-man or
I guess they're gonna continue to reboot
spider-man but they're gonna be able to
bring on Kevin Figgy and Amy Pascal any
Pascal initially was like basically
oversaw the original spider-man launch
understand Raimi 13 years ago Kevin
Feige is of course the guy who's running
the Marvel Cinematic Universe at the
moment the two of them will collaborate
on the direction that spider-man will go
or I guess they'll be kind of a the top
guys on the creative team when it comes
to spider-man under under Sony Pictures
now the other thing to keep in mind here
is that Sony has total control over
spider-man so I mean they have control
over the distribution they have control
over the licensing they have control
over creativity so they can overrule
Kevin Feige if they want to or I guess
it's kind of a in any Pascal they have
the ultimate say in the direction the
spider-man goes in but here's the
question here's the million dollar
question what film is Marvel going to or
as good as one we're gonna have
spider-man appear in my money and the
money on us guys here at the weekly pool
or I guess that yeah the weekly pool the
YouTube Avengers is Civil War now that
would be amazing if we had spider-man
and Civil War
oh my god could you imagine that my
fanboy is amiss just gooing out although
it's pitiful it's absolutely pitiful I
promise you it is but
I'm really excited about this I am I'm
very very stoked
what's also gonna happen here is that
there's gonna be some collaboration that
is to say some characters from the
Marvel Cinematic Universe or I guess
they're looking at the idea of crossing
them over into Sony in spider-man now
what I'm hoping is that later on down
the road we'll see more integration here
where will basically see Sony still
owning the property of spider-man or
maybe some kind of profit-sharing will
will see Sony saying Marvel you can have
like 35 percent of the gross revenue
we'll take 65% and he can appear in more
Marvel Cinematic Universe films I don't
really know that's the direction they're
gonna take again this is all really
tentative this came out 20 minutes ago
because right now it's 12 o'clock in the
morning and Benning was the one that
told me about it but he was one that's
to me the Lincoln said hey guys I don't
know if you know but like the biggest
news involving Marvel just came out so
I'm actually surprised that it didn't
leak to be honest I'm surprised I know
there were rumors and stuff you know and
then the last thing we saw what the
whole Sony hack was well you know they
want to reboot it but I didn't I was
surprised in week out so they've been
pretty hush-hush about this I imagine
there were a lot of closed-door meetings
but nonetheless that's where things
stand at the moment spider-man is still
owned by Sony spider-man will still be
distributed by Sony sony Sony still owns
the concept of spider-man that is to say
spider-man and the end of films anything
other than basically I guess print media
that is to say comic books Marvel is
gonna be working with Sony to bring
spider-man to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe for film and the models gonna
be working with Sony to release I guess
reboots spider-man for the Sony version
of whatever the spider-man series will
be I guess spider-man and his amazing
friends or something like that so anyway
figured I'd make a quick video four
minutes long so don't lambaste me
because it's too short but yeah so I'll
catch you guys later peace
[Music]